Facebook is warning it's more than 2
billion users that their privacy may
have been compromised by more
third-party apps the company apologized
in ads in US and British newspapers
yesterday's for the leak of data for
more than 50 million users to Cambridge
analytically ads said in part we expect
there are others vladimir duthiers of
our streaming network cbsn is here with
the growing backlash Vlad good morning
good morning a new reuters/ipsos poll
finds just 41% of Americans trust
Facebook to obey US privacy laws
compared to more than 60% for Amazon and
Google and criticism of Facebook is
coming from tech Titans like Tim Cook
and Elon Musk to government officials
Mark Zuckerberg didn't mention Cambridge
analytic ABAI name but it's clear the
Facebook CEO had it in mind when he took
out the newspaper ads I promise to do
better for you he said we have a
responsibility to protect your
information if we can't we don't deserve
it
Cambridge analytic the British political
consultancy firm had improperly obtained
personal data on some 50 million
Facebook users that's a small piece on
Face the Nation Mark Warner vice
chairman of the Senate Intelligence
Committee called on Zuckerberg to come
clean about Cambridge analytics which
helped identify supporters for President
Donald Trump's campaign and build
targeted political ads I think mr.
Zuckerberg needs to come and testify
before Congress not just put an
advertisement in a newspaper Zuckerberg
who says he's willing to appear before
Congress also felt pressure from Silicon
Valley Apple CEO Tim Cook speaking in
China said the situation was dire and
welcomed more privacy protections I
think that probably some well-crafted
regulation is necessary he said Saturday
Elon Musk joined the hashtag delete
Facebook movement and took down the
Facebook pages for his companies and
Tesla and SpaceX it feels like a
snowball effect Sina editor Dan Ackerman
says the growing controversy can't be
ignored by Apple Google and other tech
companies that collect personal data
they won't just be able to say we'll try
to do better next time and then we'll
forget about it and move on to whatever
the next shiny text or E is Facebook is
investigating all third party apps that
had access to huge amounts
user data and says it will ban all apps
that mishandled it Cambridge analytic
assess the data it purchased was deleted
back in 2015 and denies using it during
the 2016 presidential election this
story is not going away no big deal
yeah Maury continued thank you lad